الصدر يرد على مطلب ايران الاعتذار عن
مصطلح الخليج العربي الامير هاري يتهم
عائلته بالتعاون مع الشيطان لتشويه سمعته
رئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي يعتذر لزيدان بعد
التصريحات الموسيقى هذه الاخبار وغيرها
منقولها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد مطالبه البرلمان الايراني زعيم التيار
الصدريه مقتدى الصدر بالاعتذار عن
استخدامه مصطلح الخليج العربي
هو التقارب العراق
وعلى عملها السياسي والتجاري داخله فيما
اطلق نشيطون واسم الخليج العربي ردا على
مطالبه طهران الصدر ورئيس الوزراء محمد
شياع السوداني بالاعتذار لاستخدامهما
مصطلح الخليج العربي بدلا من الفارسي في
تصريحات لهما مرتبطه بانطلاق خليجي 25 في
مصر
ما زال الامير هاري يتصدر وحديث الصحف
البريطانيه بسبب تصريحاته والتي كان اخرها
اتهامه لافراد العائله الملكه بالتعاون مع
الشيطان اي الصحافه الصفراء على حد وصفه
لتحسين سمعتهم على حساب سمعته وسمعت زوجته
البريطانيه او ضحاها ريان هو بعد سنوات
عديده من الاكاذيب التي قيلت عنه وعن
عائلته جاءت مرحله قرر فيها افراد العائله
المالكه التعاون مع الشيطان لاعاده تحسين
صورتهم مشيرا الى انه وضع حدا فاصلا للامر
عندما اصبح تحسين صورتهم على حسابه وحساب
افراد اسرته الاخرين
في نهايه سعيده لواقعه عامل نظافه بورسعيد
الذي تعرض للاهانه من قبل موظف اثناء عمله
والتي اغضبت المصريين قررت السلطات توفيره
وظيفه مناسبه له والتحقيق مع موظف
الاشغالات المسؤول عن الواقعه كانت وسائل
التواصل او مواقع التواصل ضجه خلال
الساعات الماضيه بمقطع فيديو اظهر اهانه
عامل نظافه في مدينه بورسعيد من موظفي
الحي بالمدينه بعد مصادره العرب التي يعمل
عليها لكسب قوت يومه فيما قال مصور
الواقعه انه لم يتدخل لانقاذ العامل بل
فضل تصوير المقطع حتى يصل للمسؤولين وتتم
محاسبه الموظف
بعدما اطلق تصريحات عن زين الدين زيدان
بشكل اثار ضجه واسعه واستياء من اللاعبين
والسياسيين كذلك قدم رئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي
لكره القدم نوال لوغريتا اعتذاره لمدرب
ريال مدريد السابق لوجرت قال في بيان انه
يعترف بادلاء تعليقات سخيفه تسببت في سوء
الفهم مضيفا ان زيدان يدرك الاحترام
الكبير الذي يكنه له ككل الشعب الفرنسي
وكان لوغريت هجمه زيدان خلال مقابله
اذاعيه لدى سؤاله عن احتمالات توليه تدريب
منتخب البرازيل بعد تبدد فرصته في تدريب
المنتخب الفرنسي قائلا لا اكترث لمشواره
التدريبيه ابدا لو اتصل بي لن ارفع
السماعه
وفي خبرنا الاخير شهد الطلب على تذاكر
المباراه المرتقبه بين باريس سان جيرمان
ونجوم نادي الهلال والنصر على كاس موسم
الرياض شهد اقبالا تاريخيا غير مسبوق بعد
ساعه قليله من طرح التذاكر رئيس الهيئه
العامه للترفيه تركي ال الشيخ قال في
تصريحات ان الطلبه على التذاكر ضخم جدا
وتجاوز مليونير طلب من اشخاص من نحو 170
دوله حول العالم لحضور المباراه التي
ستقام يوم التاسع عشر من يناير الجاري
فيما تحظى هذه المواجهه المرتقبه باهتمام
كبير اذ- ستجمع ليونيل ميسي وكريستيانو
رونالدو للمره الاولى منذ عامين تقريبا
[موسيقى]